the PM convene in his cabinet in London
he'd have rather been breakfast in in
Berlin Brussels or perhaps Paris
finalizing a brexit deal but his offer
to the EU trashed a 30-minute phone call
between Boris Johnson and the German
Chancellor did not go well a number-10
saw sane Angela Merkel believes a deal
is overwhelmingly unlikely and going
further saying that you didn't see
minded to strike a brexit deal on mr.
Johnson's terms ever so it's not it
absolutely not no we've got an offer on
the table to them it's a very fair offer
it carves Northern Ireland out for the
single market but keeps northern aren't
in the customs union we think that's
perfectly fair and the right way to go
for the knighted Kingdom mr. Johnson
keen to show you the President of the
European Parliament his plan is the
right way to any point in still talking
but in reality hopes fading fast for a
thumbs up from Brussels the two sides
still miles apart the fact is that Boris
Johnson's repeated that he would like a
deal I invited him to present proposals
that are workable and are not just ideas
like the ones listed in the past days
those are not a deal with talks stutter
in the blame game in full flow on the
one hand the government says it still
wants a deal while on the other unnamed
Johnson allies are trying to pin looming
failure on the EU labour says the
government aren't playing straight the
government put proposals on the table
that would never going to work they were
designed to fail and instead of reacting
and changing their proposals they're now
collapsing the talks and engaging in a
in a reckless blame game this Minister
updated MPs on No Deal preparations
trying to pin it all on Labour faced
with the delaying disruptive and denying
tactics of the Opposition we
on behalf of the seventeen point four
million enough enough enough
we need to leave officially the UK and
the EU aren't quite ready to fold on
these talks but to all intents and
purposes it's game over this negotiation
now dead in the water and number ten are
now trying to shift the blame onto
someone else onto Parliament the EU even
the course anyone but Boris Johnson as
they lay the groundwork for a vicious
people versus the establishment general
election Parliament suspended again
tonight but MPs will return next week
Boris Johnson will set out his domestic
policy agenda but the real issue facing
this Parliament is brexit alone the
battle between No Deal versus a brexit
extension entering the endgame bathra B
Sky News West Winstone